is this a hoax or something
oh my god yeah right
really
oh my god just carrots
[Laughter]
oh look at jessica's face she cares look
at that oh my
god good morning everybody today we are
going to a big mood shoot tiff's getting
ready right now and i am just packing my
camera equipment it's been really fun uh
hanging out with the girls getting their
perspective on life i actually love
working side by side with tiff i think
it allows for me and tiff to also go
through the battles and trenches of work
together and that actually gives us a
lot of skill sets to also you know work
on relationships and stuff like that
working together professionally has
actually strengthened our personal
relationship but anyways before i load
up the car huge shout out to philo for
sponsoring today's video thank you very
much so i've been using fylo for the
past couple of days and i've been
creating my fall phylo playlist and it's
one of those playlists where tiff and i
if we have any downtime we like watching
90s sitcoms it's nostalgic for us we
grew up in the era and seeing characters
in that setting with that fashion just
kind of brings us back to somewhere warm
and fuzzy so we like to cozy up and
watch 90s sitcoms so if you don't know
what filo is filo is a live and
on-demand tv streaming service they got
over 60 channels and a lot of my
favorite shows in their current season
it's easy to use they have an app on
roku apple tv your phone your laptop so
you can literally watch and record tv
anywhere you go and the best part is
it's 25 a month and that's my favorite
part about filo we're saving over a
hundred dollars a month going with filo
and also the fact that they can save
your recorded shows for up to a year so
if you want to check them out click the
link in my description box and use my
code then one month to download filo and
to get one month free thank you follow
for sponsoring today's video all right
on a big mood buenos dias
good morning today
is a saturday and
as you can see on the big mood set aka
nikki's house and i wanted to talk about
how we set up because casey and i are
the production team for our podcast now
and we set up this whole thing so we can
be ready to film and i completely forgot
to vlog the actual setup so i'm just
gonna talk about what we did all of this
stuff back here we're not all of it
because here's casey he's setting up
cameras right now but uh some of this
stuff
is what we put up for our set so for
example we put up this picture frame we
cover the window so we can have
consistent lighting because we shoot all
day we also add these little twinkly
lights and then nikki usually has these
three plants on the window over here but
then we move them for the set and then
she has a whole bunch of pillows so
the circle pillows are all put in that
bench when we're not filming so then i
bring out all the pillows casey sets up
all of the
mics so there's four mics and he also
sets up the lights and
the cameras and we have three cameras
and he sets up the audio stuff so then
once we're actually filming he's like
looking
at the levels to make sure we don't peek
while we're filming
peeking yeah hi jess you look gorgeous
by the way by the way i'm speaking of
peeking oh i love it i love it it's
gonna be 35 pretty soon
we are peeking
okay so peeking
i almost dropped my camera
there's a brand new camera by the way um
so peaking means when the sound is too
high it ends up getting like distorted
and really like fuzzy sounding like just
really bad audio quality oh yeah how are
you gina i'm good i've been busy i know
look at you being on uh g4 and
everything being all busy all week and
having an actual job and being an adult
first time in your life it sucks you
guys have to do work so much work i only
have like four hours of sleep at night
because i can't i'm not used to it
i'm still adjusting to it yeah and it's
fun i can't complain like i'm living
like i'm literally living my dream but
it's so tiring i know like why you sleep
when you die right yeah
i mean
just enjoy the ride you know i am when
it's over it's over and entertainment
doesn't last forever
exactly you're killing it i'm so proud
of you
let me try my new zoom on my new camera
it's so slow
not very impressive wait well focus
either come on you camera you're feeling
let me get this look at this eventually
we'll get there
we'll get there eventually i was trying
to do this i was trying to show the
belly it's going to be a very blurred
effect but it doesn't look very big
i'm 19 weeks i'm trying to get something
it looks like ugly
well it is bigger than last time you
guys saw me oh yeah for sure
see
look at your butt jess your butt's as
big as my belly
[Laughter]
did you see what we just did cheetah
look at this [ __ ] again dude again i'm
i'm her body but backwards like flat on
this side
you guys are yin yang
cute
that's adorable
oh it cracks me up but yeah i am 19
weeks now and baby is doing great how do
you mask that how many months is it
it's about five weeks five years i mean
sorry
the month
yeah it's about five weeks five days you
know it's five days long for you
baby just doing good but okay back to
the set though because i want to tell
you what we do
so
we also do a sound check for me real
quick update mike and just uh yeah
we can keep vlogging we also do that
we casey and i we make sure that
i should not have sat like that my
my thigh hit the belly a little bit
um
so yeah so then we do a sound check on
each mic to make sure that the levels
are great oh my god i never thought
about that you have to sit a certain way
so you don't accidentally
leg your baby yes i just liked it and
then sometimes i'm swinging my arm and
my arm hits my belly because i'm not
used to it being popped out oh my god
it's really weird those two are good
yeah so
this one's good okay let me i'm slower
these days okay be patient
so then we just continue to do sound
checks and every single set and then
also what we're doing is making sure
that the mic is in a comfortable
position
for whoever's gonna sit in each spot so
then we check this one
what we forgot to do or we need to still
do is move this plant we move this
closer and then we're done but yeah all
this stuff here i grabbed from nikki's
like
nikki's home like all over the place i
grabbed these items so we can fill that
space i also lay out a blanket here
because
there is
nothing but white behind that that
blanket so we want to break up all the
white and like add color and like make
it make the set just really pop and like
visually pleasing
[Music]
so then this is what the set looks like
in the end ta-da
now
it is 11 o'clock gotta get all the girls
to come down now and start because we
filmed four episodes every time we get
together and this weekend is a two day
shoot which means we're gonna try to
film a total of eight episodes and
today's exciting because julia's coming
oh don't worry i got stuff for you
because yeah we're filming a halloween
episode for this weekend i'm really
really looking forward to seeing julia
because the last time i saw her is when
we told her that we were pregnant and i
just love julia's present so i'm excited
to see her today and then another thing
we have set up is the crafties
so this is nikki's doing or steve
because i think steve's the one that
does grocery shopping so thank you steve
but yeah we set up some snacks here
while we film so we can munch away right
already been eating chips and salsa for
breakfast
that's your breakfast i mean it is
breakfast i had a banana too nice sweet
raw meat
smoked meat
raw meat i don't know it's not wrong
yeah it's smoke
yeah you know what's funny about this
platter
i can only have
i think this and this and that's it yeah
you can't have it yeah i can't have the
oh wait i didn't know it was olives okay
never mind i have all those you can have
this cheese i don't know what is or
actually i don't want to eat that one
because i don't like pepper jack okay
but i can't eat it you can you can yeah
i can even this i can i can technically
drink a
glass of this but i'm not i'm not
drinking alcohol but quickly
technically the doctor says it's okay
but i'm not gonna do it
uh just one glass of red wine is fine
true
[Music]
all right we just had lunch it was
disgusting
we tried a new restaurant and didn't
work out but it's okay
i actually didn't mind mine but everyone
else
pissed my friends off yeah almost all of
us were like this is going in the
garbage not good lunch but anyway i will
talk about something that is good which
is julia
luna is back she's here she's gonna be
on big food
and look forward to that episode because
or actually we're filming two episodes
with her we're playing a game where we
get to know her really really well and
then we're going to guys already know
we're going to get to know you okay
deeper level right because this game
goes there but it's so good to see yeah
the last time we saw each other was when
i told you i was pregnant i know and
then the last time i saw gina was when i
dropped off her birthday present like
last year last year's birthday yeah
she told me she hasn't used it yet
because it was too pretty what is it
what'd you get her she got me a sailor
moon loose powder but the
case that it comes in is so pretty
you can still keep the case
oh i missed you so much no you can't use
it oh i forgot julia look at look at
what i was wearing earlier but i took
them off because it made me feel like
michael jackson
but look there's nothing to do with what
she's talking about yeah nothing at all
no but look i was wearing these cat
socks that you got me for christmas or
my birthday or something you always get
the cutest socks and i was wearing them
but look the reason why i felt like
michael jackson's because i'm wearing
black shoes
and then like with these
oh my god i'm the opposite
oh yeah let me help you look at me
[Laughter]
oh thank you
they look cute
super cute thank you so much for coming
thanks for inviting me yeah and then
look look at this belly i know
yeah i've been i've been like i feel
like i've like still stalk you guys and
i'm just like i kind of want to create
because you should text us more often
you get to keep up with us but we can't
keep up with you that's true we should
have more hangouts no make more dents
yes hey guys so we're finally wrapped
a full day of shooting big mood we're
having dinner here steve finally came
out
i'm definitely out of the hole
so he was gone all day working on crypto
stuff being a crypto king oh i like your
shirt by the way where did you think i
had this shirt at um
big mood store.com
was mouthing
[Music]
bigmoodstore.com and it says
whatever phase you're in you're
that's a great ad remember she's drunk
it's
what is it
and in case you guys haven't heard on
this channel this phrase is very
meaningful because um we said it on the
show and the full phrase i heard this
from my yoga teacher and she said just
like the sun you two will rise out of
darkness and just like the moon no
matter what phase you're in you're
always whole so then we created these
shirts
um
well it's not her quote because i asked
her because i'm friends with her shout
out to grace yeah and like she she was
just like yeah i want to see i just
heard it one day i think she stole it
from her yoga okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh look at chris's face she cares look
at that oh my god
[Music]
yeah sometimes i'm like that too jess
like i don't know what i'm feeling for i
feel my own pulse in my own fingertips
[Music]
kick again
kick again auntie just needs to feel you
are you even alive yeah i think that the
trick is is that she can feel everything
because it's from the inside of her yeah
we're kind of like fumbling around with
our fingers with my hands too that's why
i tell people like oh they're kicking
like yeah i felt it with my hand maybe
it's so slight that i don't know what
i'm looking for so we have this app this
big it is as big as a mango
oh
it's about right wait i remember it was
like
it was like a bean like this i remember
i remember being so nervous because you
you told us about it when it was before
the 10 weeks and
i had googled it and i was like oh no
the 10 weeks was like crucial
or
[Laughter]
so i've seen like a generic picture of
what a baby does as it's growing and all
the organs are literally shoved up yeah
the the woman's body it's like up here
like your intestines are should be down
here yeah like up here now when you have
like diarrhea you can feel it right here
up here oh come on don't smile so much
this is the only time you smile about
that
do you think your poop is like this
isn't the normal one
it's like she's a vacuum cleaner
salesman
all right please leave my house
like i love you kid but now you want to
feel the baby
what was that
yeah like i love you but
i can't wait to stand with gina in
[Laughter]
i've never felt a baby kick i feel like
i would i would cry and throw up the
same time this happened
i'm scared i'm actually kind of scared
am i okay you're gonna feel it that much
because i already tried i just feel like
i'd be so grossed out yeah dude this is
more girl and girl i'm used to it
[Laughter]
it's me your thea gina i just want to
let you know that i'll probably be the
favorite auntie and the drunk one that's
me uh if you come out and you see like
oh that's weird why is it an asian girl
yellow here this makes sense that's me i
also smell like liquor and
hot cheeto dust yeah so you'll know
exactly who it is i'm also the one
that's constantly cussing you out
it'll be fine once you meet me you'll
you'll know so if you can do me a favor
just give me a kick real quick you're a
mexican you guys are great at soccer so
just give me a quick go
softy
[Laughter]
you exist you are the biggest soccer
[Laughter]
holy sh this thing's real dude that's
crazy
you're so cute i love you i want to
bully the crap out of you
[Laughter]
i can't tell if i'm feeling it or not
that that's like it's the faintest thing
where it feels like a
yeah it's like i think you're feeling it
okay that must be it then it sort of
feels like i'm feeling gas going through
yourself i'm just moving you know like
like if you have like bubble guts and
it's just like making its way through
that yeah
like other times though it's like a
straight up like
like a jets cute i want to be his buenos
diaz
today is another beautiful day today's
sunday casey and i slept over mickey's
house so did jess and gina they're
upstairs we slept in steve's office
though and he has a pull out couch so we
slept on this bed
pretty comfortable i actually woke up
with my tongue super swollen like
um you could tell but
it's like really really swollen and i
have like one of those like tongue
pimple things that i i call them some
pimples
but yeah
so it's kind of hard to speak like it's
kind of hard to
to talk i had this tongue pimple
yesterday too my tongue just kept
getting like
stuck
in words yeah i just hope that the
tongue swelling will go down today
because even right now it's kind of
difficult to speak a little bit yeah
we'll see that's my challenge for today
baby's doing good i actually didn't
bring my pregnancy pillow and the last
time that we did a two-day shoot and
that we slept over i did bring my
pregnancy pillow but not this time i
just bought my my tiny little travel
pillow because after we film
we're gonna be going and spending some
time in malibu so i'm like i can't take
my big old pregnancy
pillow to the resort we're going to in
malibu so that's why i brought my little
travel one and i definitely missed it i
missed my pregnancy pillow all right so
we've filmed one episode
and we filmed a second episode in the
second episode we got a very special
beautiful guest
you're amazing and you smell amazing oh
and she's for you guys she's
she's
how is
look at this she at this beauty oh my
gosh she's who i want to be
right spf yes all of that shower
she has a
daughter
who is absolutely beautiful her mini me
she'll be 24 in november what is that
mom i was a teen mom we relate to a lot
of things and we talked about that what
was our episode today about yeah common
relationship mistakes super common that
we only got through
not all of them
yeah we actually have more in the list
yeah but it's so nice to see you because
we haven't seen each other since like
the early pandemic yeah early pandemic
days too long
so long and then we want to just have
you here forever forever i'm never
leaving you're never getting married
yeah i love it and like chance looks
great i energy too because that first
episode
i was like oh my god i'm really like let
me wake up and then right now i'm gonna
just throw sparkles yeah emmy you're in
this episode yes i am yes this is the
second to last episode for today that's
right and i've trained nikki she's been
trained by the best yeah
i know with your m m shirt too look at
you
yeah so you're gonna be doing sound
that's right no i look really
professional watch like click it
not too much you can't use an expert
just a tiny little bit
you got to just move your hand and it
looks like you're actually moving the
thing i'm going to like look like a
painting you just have to put a lot in
your body
but you don't actually move the [ __ ]
things that much and you gotta like like
your [ __ ] vibe into your own [ __ ] oh
no you know what you need to do but hold
on i was about to say that i'm like you
need to fix your your headphone and you
have to do this thingy we have the
headphone here yeah your shoulder there
we go
[Music]
what are you doing gina oh my gosh
you got the rock
what going on
[Music]
unless you want to like make that a
little different and then you guys we're
on the back side yeah there we go
[Music]
that's side by side right there do you
want my maternity pants lighter jeans
they're jeans you need lighter jeans
it's okay okay so instead of filming
this is what we do we just mess around
and then we wait yeah we waste a lot of
time
yeah because we have to do this episode
and then one more episode and then we're
done for the whole weekend yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
no
i want them on opposite sides because it
creates more drama
oh yeah exactly
they're gonna be like they're fighting
they're gonna get divorced yeah that's
it they they're sitting across yeah like
way further away they're gonna get it
you know what
is probably cheating on tempo gina
because they're sitting next to each
other all right it's the last episode of
the weekend and it's a halloween episode
and look at jess look at this you did
your own face makeup it's amazing and
you did it so fast
i did it really fast yeah dude you look
so good
and then like a few teeth you can keep
my cats too mine took three hours
three hours look at this girl queen of
hearts
i love how you did your makeup just like
her too i should have done that last
year for all or two years ago that looks
good for you because i forgot my costume
and tiff brought the hat and here i am
oh my glory
where's your little whip thingy
oh with his head
[Laughter]
yeah sad boys
you sound really asian
tweedledee
i should call them fat boys in the the
movie with johnny depp oh that's the one
you're referring to yeah so what are you
dressed up as uh the the audio guy
the technician
yeah
who are you it pops up so this is an
accidental minnie mouse costume so i
recently purchased this skirt and this
shirt and then when i tucked in the
shirt i realized oh my god i look like
minnie mouse yeah i have the ears i was
like perfect yeah and then we got the
black candles look at those
i'm not virgin with them so yeah
non-virgin there won't be any souls
coming out
yeah we we changed all the mood lighting
to red so
yeah last step
and then we're done and then we have
nothing to look forward to
so i'm not looking forward to anything
jesse's in character
oh [ __ ] she's like cheese
you look like
[Music]
you're all happy
why are you so happy
i'm just like what if i what if you were
vlogging the whole time and i was just
like just
waiting to just take your soul i just
love the contrast because he looks so
angry i know so i have to be all cute
happy minnie mouse i look like the queen
of hearts with steve jobs
i want to present to you my next
additional
it's innovative
innovative wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you